Latin America is perhaps the region with
the least military ambition in the
world.
The government spends relatively little
on the fence and in general with some
exceptions,
creating large and powerful armies bids,
not exactly a priority like this.
The subjects of the armed forces has
been very controversial in the region in
recent years,
and that's no one's there because the
second half of the 20th century,
it wasn't exactly a quiet time.
The Latin America throughout this
period,
and especially in the 19 sixties and 19
seventies,
this region was one of the territories
in the world which was the most effected
by military force.
What about Amada
for the easiest?
Practically every country in the region
participated in what kind of became a
macabre tradition of military groups and
of course plenty of repression.
For example,
let's take a look at 1978 in that year
among other countries,
Argentina,
Bolivia,
Brazil,
Chile,
Ecuador,
Paraguay,
Peru,
Cuba,
Nicaragua,
Honduras,
El Salvador,
Panama,
as even the peaceful year ago when I
went under a military dictatorship,
and do forgive me if I left anything
else because you could see it's a pretty
long list.
Dictators of every kind existed left
rights pro us,
andy us harder,
softer,
but well,
they all had one common elements.
That was repression.
Yeah.
In the framework of the Cold War and
block struggles,
many of these dictatorships,
they were supported by the United States
under the framework of what was later
known as Operation Condo,
a sinister intelligence collaboration
plan.
Fortunately in the military,
dictatorships of the yellows,
Argentina,
Pinochet's,
Chile,
Alfredo strossner's,
Paraguayan Joelle figure raters,
Brazil,
ends border,
Barry's Uruguay.
They will all aided by the CIA in order
to achieve a single prosecutes and
annihilate the political opposition,
especially the leftist groups that were
supported by the Soviet regime.
Yeah,
of course.
As you might expect,
the dictatorships forged under the other
political color.
They weren't any better.
Not at all
facts
during this.
It isn't hard to imagine why the armed
forces issue has been so controversial.
Well more than 30 years have now passed
since this dark periods,
and in this video we're going to be
answering several questions.
What is the current state of Latin
America is all nice?
What functions do they really have and
do they pose any risk to the democracy
and freedom of these countries?
Well,
that's dive in.
He's in Latin America.
Before we begin,
and just out of curiosity,
well let me ask you a question.
Which do you think are the strongest,
most powerful armies in Latin America?
Well,
this is always quite subjective,
but according to the global firepower
index from 2017,
which is an indicator that attempts to
measure which armies and more powerful
and the different parameters.
These are the top five in Latin America,
first place.
Not really surprising.
It goes to Brazil,
which is the greatest regional power.
This is followed by you in this order.
Mexico,
Argentina,
Peru,
and Colombia.
Yeah.
The truth is
the Latin America is the region with
these small list of budget dedicated to
defense in 2016,
it was just over one percent of its GDP,
which is about $67,000,000,000.
This expenditure is much lower than the
global average,
especially because last and American
armies tend to have quite a high number
of soldiers
to get some idea.
In total,
the region has over one point seven,
$3 million soldiers.
Of course,
the combination of a low budget with
many soldiers needs to outdated armies
with plenty of operational problems.
Let's take a look at the most important
army.
The Brazilian army Brazil spends 23
point $7,000,000,000 every year,
which kind of on the face of it seems
like quite a lot,
right?
Well,
the problem is that the army has 340,000
soldiers,
which means that three quarters of the
budget goes to salaries and pensions.
If to this,
we add basic supplies,
then the money left for equipment is
very,
very low.
As in the rest of Latin America ratio is
a similar.
On average,
70 percent of the money goes directly to
salaries.
In other words,
Latin American armies usually have a lot
of soldiers and very little equipment.
Looking inward.
Sorry.
So
if we talk about armies wars and
conflicts between countries,
we could say that last and America is
one the most peaceful regions in the
world.
The last arms conflict occurred in 1995
and what was later known as the Sun Epa
wore this involved Ecuador and Peru,
but no formal declaration of war was
ever made
is that the trend has begun that has
made Latin America a benchmark every
time there was a conflict between two
countries,
instead of threatening each other with
bombs and cannons.
Those involved resorts do international
justice.
This is what is currently happening,
for example,
with the conflicts between Bolivia and
Chili over the sea fronts may conflict
and that is being resolved at the
International Court of Justice in The
Hague.
Live your replies to the lawsuit against
Chile at The Hague court for cxs.
However,
internally well things,
they are completely different.
We could say that Latin America has the
record for being the most peaceful
region and at the same time the most
violence one.
Here's that between countries,
there is no serious threat of war,
but the situation is different.
If we talk about internal violence,
more incredible than that though is the
fact that one in three homicides that
occur every year globally,
it take place in Latin America,
so because apparently all enemies there
are Latin American military forces to
focus on at home tasks such as
confronting gorillas,
drug traffic has,
or just dealing with violence in
general.
In fact,
in the region,
it is becoming increasingly common for
military forces to replace the police
and security and surveillance tasks.
The problem here is that evidence shows
that soldiers aren't really good at
playing the role of the police.
Insufficient
solution.
It's what we might think of first.
Crime rates in Brazil or Mexico far from
decreasing have increased since soldiers
began participating in citizen security
in the five most dangerous cities in the
world.
Caracas,
Acapulco,
San Pedro,
Sula,
central districts and Victoria have a
military presence and well that's not
all or abuse extra judicial detentions
or collateral victims have also
increased with military presence which
further favors and feed say culture of
violence.
This is something that is unfortunately
40 widespread in the region nowadays.
The
is that soldiers are forces trained for
war in order to eliminate the enemy,
not to impose order and the rule of law
to achieve rule of law,
what is needed to detectives,
courts,
judges,
local police forces,
and even citizen collaboration,
not the military.
We can take a look at what has happened.
For example,
in Mexico,
as soon as he became president in
December 2006,
Philippe Calderon declared war on drugs
and placed the army on the streets.
Since then,
not only it has narcotics trafficking,
not decreased,
but homicide rates of triples the army.
It's simply not enough.
They can of course,
lender hands in very serious cases,
but they cannot be a police force.
It just doesn't work.
And yes,
I do know that corruption in the police
as a problem,
but this isn't simply fixed by resorting
to using the army.
And indeed,
this actually leads to two other major
problems.
The first one is political risk.
So consider this Latin America's armed
forces must be anti imperialist Eva
Morales.
Well,
why do you want me to say to me?
Seeing politicians use military forces
to defend that political ideas,
whatever they might be,
seems very,
very dangerous.
Using that power of force is always
going to be super tempting.
This is what has happened,
for example,
in Venezuela where the armed forces have
pretty much become something like a
Praetorian guard.
For Nicolas Maduro has bolivarian regime
as if that wasn't enough.
There is also the big corruption
problems.
See the military industry is really
opaque and it's got huge contracts which
are two pretty basic ingredients for
corruption.
Just have a look at what happens in 2010
in the Dominican Republic.
In 2010,
a major corruption scandal affect the
Dominican armed forces due to the fraud
and the purchase of eight Super Tucano
aircraft from the Brazilian company
Embraer.
It is suspected that $87,000,000
remained in the hands of members of the
country's political and military
hierarchy.
Lillian Bobbia,
professor at Bentley University in
Massachusetts,
and that's just one example and it's not
even the most important one.
So taking all of this into account and
maybe it would be a good idea to
consider some sort of military alliance,
Latin American NATO.
No.
Allow me to propose an idea that may
seem just the touch crazy now based on
what we've just discussed,
wouldn't it be a good idea to think
about building a great military alliance
and alliance in which different
countries could organize and provide
different units and bodies for different
types of tasks?
This would have several major advantage.
Military influence over political power
would decrease and sovereignty would be
guaranteed for all countries in
addition,
and if necessary during natural
disasters,
Latin American countries could have an
army that could deploy rapidly where
they are needed.
It could also push for much needed Latin
American integration and to increase
this region's role in the world of
politics
x,
it would free many resources,
both economic and human and this could
be used to promote citizen security and
reduce violence rates in these
countries.
In a way
the European Union,
they're actually trying to do something
similar.
So while it may sound like a bit of a
crazy idea at first,
maybe it's not like crazy after all,
for example,
Costa Rica suppressed,
it's all me decades ago and the results
in terms of security have been better
than those of its neighbors.
We've said before here on visual politic
that the 21st century is going to be
India century and it's probably China
and Asia in general.
Now we're wondering,
maybe not in America too.
Well now you've heard our opinion here
at visual politic and now it's your
turn.
Do you agree that soldiers can be used
to replace the police for matters of
security?
Well,
do let us know in the comments section
below.
Also,
please do like and subscribe for brand
new videos every Monday and Thursday.
Also do check out our friends at the
reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
that one on mine,
and this is always thank you for awhile.